Johanna Frank I've ever had in my mouth
right now oh my god it says lit a little
bit huh Wow yeah hey what's going on
everybody for first view feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today I'm joined by
comedian Artie way you know him from his
decades and stand-up his books TV and
movies as well as the Howard Stern Show
you can catch him on HBO's hit series
crashing and at a comedy club near you
Artie welcome to the show
oh you're a nice guy man if you're gonna
eat hot sauce for me Artie it will
extend well at least meet you halfway
I'm not gonna be here how are you with
hot foods good I'm I grew up Italian my
mother my mom's with Sonny action
particularly used to fry a hot green
peppers you know what Allah voya land
you can put down on anything that would
taste good and they were very hot you're
experimenting it was insane
that was insane you know but I'm into it
I like it
[Music]
and you'll start at the handle RT and
then we'll work our way to the end of
the panel so the first wing is with
Valentina oh it's on already
[Music]
when I eat I end up looking like Vito at
the firm Oh Google help me laughs you're
a frog says we're want to do on hot ones
I want to start by taking it way back
when you were moonlighting as a New York
City cab driver well try to get your
stand-up career off the ground did
anyone ever bail on a fair did anyone
ever try to sneak out of the cab on you
wife what'd you do well I don't want to
run down you know some serial killer for
a couple of bucks and I very yellow cab
guy no I saw a cab driver get shot right
next to me I'm 56 and I was trying to
get out of the car without paying and he
went for him and the kids the kids that
got a pistol shot right through the the
under of the chair their seat went right
through the guy and survived it from
what I heard but I had a hospital bit of
pain here I never got robbed though you
ready to move on Artie in my life got
some ice water coming in will sizzle
reel so you once distinguish the Artie
Lange show by saying it's for real men
in the sea of [ __ ] and these days
there does seem to be a growing
disconnect between the fan in the
nosebleed section right and then the
dweebs who cover professional sports
yeah so what I want to do is bounce some
Hot Topic sports issues off of you
because I think that the sports media
misses the Artie Lange perspective okay
you got it as a Giants diehard
yeah what are your thoughts on Odell
Beckham jr. I'm gonna be like my uncle
Sonny watching football games okay I
stopped our dad shut up and I was
literally doing that when he did the dog
pissing on the before huh we didn't win
you don't have a ring yet if you're
gonna act like that you gotta have a
ring
you know Lawrence Taylor what was always
a bit of a jerk oil but he didn't go way
far but till he got a ring you know he
hasn't won anything hotel yet does Alex
Rodriguez dating Jennifer Lopez give you
a more favorable or less favorable
opinion laughs if that was possible you
know in the 70s a job the Yankees all
had jobs in the summer they were
plumbers
why'd you look like me they don't want
to go home you know and I related to
that now I don't relate to the man she
she's a bad through with the had crooked
I want to kill him is it true that you
can name every World Series match up in
winter since 1949 from 49 to 50 I could
name the two people two teams in the
series who won 1971 1971 the Pirates
beat the Orioles in seven games 1959 in
1959 the the Dodgers beat the White Sox
Sandy Koufax 1990 1990 the Reds swept
the A's this is how Jack buck Joe Buck's
father started that telecast hears bombs
flyball left Larkins Aires got it that's
the way this one starts to do give you a
lot what's your position on the Red Sox
stealing signs with the help of an Apple
watch I have a very very love/hate thing
going out with Boston I always hating
them as a kid Yankees Red Sox Bucky
that's the whole thing but why I do
stand-up in Boston I make more money
there than anywhere they're just
down-to-earth great people I love them I
got kicked off the entire corporate
circuit because I made this joke at an
apple party they had I said in the gay
community Tim Cook's come is known as
applesauce you said that at an Apple
event yeah I mean you know it's not an
insult really and it's like kind of made
me in fun the applesauce makes sense you
know we have to know laughter I my
follow-up was is is your is apple juice
and again nothing I was escorted out of
the facility
I don't know would you think that's an
insult you know what I think if you're
gonna hire Artie Lange did you get your
event then I should deal with the
consequences whatever they are that's my
that would have been a perfect
this is a good idea but sitting in a
major building in New York you do
anything like you must shoot it out of
his garage this is debo I did the
billion-dollar Storrow a block for me
that's a great Segway Rd I love when
that happens on hot ones because I'd be
remiss if I didn't talk to you about
your time at the Howard Stern Show I
know that there are a lot of fans that
miss you who is your favorite wack pack
Beetlejuice I mean it's hard to beat
Beetlejuice that's an astonishing life I
decided to get help when he told me I
was a mess and I just fell off the stage
in Vegas drunk I can call me let the
voicemail Artie's beat you'll miss when
the [ __ ] toothless black [ __ ] says
you're a mesh you get help besides your
assistant Teddy which Stern staffer did
you fight with most often quite a Bobby
Gary when you throw out that first pitch
and I goofed on him he was mad about it
it was always really me I'm like are you
talking to the same guy when I call in a
dying of Harold you're old you play it
on the air so you throw out a first
pitch like my the Olsen twins and I
can't [ __ ] make fun of it me Gary
fall off Afghanistan II weasels way into
that who's their favorite recurring
guest between George Takei Jim Breuer
and John Stamos George Takei
we become friends still to this day the
meanest thing we've ever done
I think I'm sterner I've ever done in my
life not saying a lot I came out to
George Takei and hit him and he fell for
hook line and sinker
I was gonna come out and the next day on
radio he's gonna help me throw it I felt
so terrible I said to Howard I never
does work I said we have to say we have
to call up and say it's not but this is
a person who went through that in real
life like I felt terrible and then he
was probably so comforting to you right
he was the nicest person ever said he
had to do that like he had to tell like
his father
and we're goofing on we can't do it all
and Howard said if you tell him you're
fired
so next day he thinks I'm gonna come out
I don't we tell him it's a joke this is
his reaction he laughter goes oh you
scoundrel
[Laughter]
got by now back there I'm gonna feel
that one in the morning so as anyone
who's followed your career knows you've
cheated the devil a million times there
are a lot of city miles on the odometer
besides Vegas where does one find the
best strip clubs in the country
Delana Tampa Houston I had a chicken
Arizona once tell me she wrote a spec
script for Everybody Loves Raymond a
stripper are you sure a comedian I go
yeah she goes do you know Ray Romano and
I said he's like my best friend I met
him twice and she goes I have a spec
script for everyone's very I said sure
go get it but she was kind of creepy and
I left without getting it like the
biggest mistake ever we have that script
right man I like that she had a hard
copy
she's like y'all let me just run through
celebrities to come in I guess and I'm
the closest to his 11 do you imagine
like I'll I'll settle for this boy fiery
Capote not that is actually don't you
enjoyed that no I actually that's like a
nice sort of classy days ago Thank You
Artie
no problem all right so every current
segment on our show called explain that
Graham where we do a deep dive hundred
gossip Instagram poll interesting
pictures that need more context when
I've been pulled over by a cop explain
that Graham I've heard well this time we
put a little twist on it for Artie Lange
we pulled some great Artie Lange
throwback so I'll show you the throwback
and then you tell me the bigger story
does that really good like if
celebrities Artie you are a celebrity
yeah laptop laptop
you look like DJ tesco wha I don't like
the reference already unexpected very
good for the kid play well it'll play
well all right Artie first things first
you and Chris Farley of the dirty work
Wow dirty work was his last movie Farley
right and in between shooting dirty work
and dying he did sign and live he hosted
it so norm said he's out of control you
got to come to the after-party to help
me watch him that's how out of control
was I was in door MacDonald
yeah our babies exactly right so what
gnorm leaves for a couple of minutes and
I see Chris disappear into a bathroom
with Andy Dick
true story five minutes he's in there he
comes out giggling norm comes back you
know what's going on I go bad news man
he went to advance woman anything for
five minutes and you know there's only
two reasons a guy goes into a bathroom
with Andy day and neither one is good
and without missing a beat norm said
Holly [ __ ] I hope he's high so good news
he was high speaking the doormat areas
you and norm yeah well there's a few
guys like a point to wealth took a
chance on me when I was even gonna go to
the joint or rehab and it was norm
Howard and Quincy Jones who did Matthew
Lee yeah we did a buddy comedy together
we met at the addition I got terrible
reviews when it came out my hometown
paper said already lying has all the
charm with date rapists true story
that's in the review so norm said to me
hey man that's [ __ ] great a date
rapist has to have way more charm than a
regular rapist he does things that are
so ballsy it takes a lot of risks and it
makes them fun but it also makes him
very dangerous one more for you Artie
there you go my man Eli Manning and
Donald Trump playing golf easily the
smartest one there me easily not even
close
you talk about two dolls I had just
roasted Trump he thought I was fun even
though he hated the last joke I did and
he asked if I would do stand-up an event
and he'll I was with me and I had just
that that fit I did about him and his
brother in the mouth-breathing that was
on an album all mine he's like a little
kid
shut up did you beat Tom Brady twice you
could be on a Hooters yacht somewhere I
had a golfing mate then he was sincere
when he was kind of like going after you
oh yeah it was like you know genuine
like that southern sucker that we think
he fits that sort of I you could run a
con on amazing
[Music]
dirty drew tiny dicks how I'm a courier
this doesn't taste like dirty Dave well
I'll call backup anyone who's heard you
singing big E's give me the loot knows
that you could have moonlit as an emcee
if you wanted to is there a common DNA
between comedy and rap in your opinion
because there's something about the
rawness of expression and rap it seems
to appeal to you yeah it would start
guys like biggie smalls I really think
that guy was some sort of genius you
know
mm that DMX guy their songs weren't
always about having the hottest chicks
or multiplying like was directly
opposite you know I'm pissed off because
I'm ugly or whatever and I got no money
and no broads and that's why I deal blow
and stuff like that it's like the other
guys did it cuz it's cool no I got a
deal code I remember II called Kanye
West's overrated has your opinion of
Kanye West evolved or do you still think
Easy's full of [ __ ] I don't care if it's
munich agrees never I'm not going there
because he's such an ass I mean he's
just such an [ __ ] but my my thinking
is will be the next president the
warning track here mm-hmm
I Palm Desert addiction so when you were
coming up and you were doing a gig in
Cincinnati whatever you would say it
would just be between you and maybe the
three to four hundred people in the
comedy club right and these days now
every punchline can go from a smartphone
to a Twitter firestorm in a matter of
minutes is that a death nail for the
modern comedian do you ever think about
it yes I do it's a great question and
that is preventing people from taking
risk you don't take risks you're not
gonna get you'll have the same seven
minutes have a sickening it used to be
like true art in the sense that it's
just you and those people in the room I
say what I got to say to get offstage
and get paid but now it's the whole
world literal and then to you've leaned
into some things that have become no-fly
zones and popular culture have you ever
been checked by another comedian on it
or is it just sort of Twitter armchair
pundants the public that are up in arms
it's funny that that's a great question
because I have Bob Schimmel told me some
what you do is just for the shock thing
I'm like I know like I never claimed to
be some great comic I just make I'm good
enough at it to make some sort of living
I don't want to be known as a good comic
I don't wanna be no I don't wanna be on
a list because then you have to answer
questions that is gonna show me to be a
fraud some of the best questions I've
ever been has that for sure you have a
good guy i shagged immediate kick I mean
yeah that's a good one that's a better
one the bomb oh yeah I'm sweating like
when someone does ask me where the stash
boxes wow yeah it's very real
yeah yeah I have a couple friends eat
these like it's like mmm you know you
gotta check their DNA some people are
crazy at the peppers and stuff young
right now I don't feel like I gotta have
kids right now
nyway the flag I want to complement
everything that you got going here Rd I
look like no skipper but I have a
Gilligan hat you know what you've been
known to apologize for your luck from
time to time yes it is very hot are you
oh my god in the day and age when the
dad bod is trending and not trying too
hard as the new gold standard I think
you could make a case for RT as a
fashion icon so what I want to do is I
want to bust out the laptop again I want
to show you some of the most iconic
party laying red carpet looks and if you
can just break down the ensemble form oh
good okay there you go bring in some
more ice water for an eagle Washburn
thank you Christian burger at the rare
cameo there's just a 50th surprise party
for me are you enjoying this I do it I'm
actually having a very good time no no I
know this is some of this is usable all
right Artie whoa that's at the beach
bowl I couldn't tie my shoes I couldn't
reach them at Neil Patrick Harris did it
for me very nice guy and uh you know we
were to exchange numbers but I played
quarterback my last pass was intercepted
by Snoop Dogg true story oh yeah look at
me there
that's uh that's me morphing into Kid
Rock I guess I never wow I love the that
I just got out of a psych ward
they take your laces could you imagine
they're afraid I'm gonna hang myself on
my laces I mean look at me so I just
never had a my mouth right now
oh my god it's just a little bit Wow
yeah all right up next you're on Fallon
oh yeah yeah I barely fit in the chair
there's like two people kit for that
chair to be in Chelsea Handler our
Fallon's chairs more comfortable than
our chairs are less comfortable than
theirs there's nothing less comfortable
this chair that's how I found it feeling
oh I love this look
I look like Dom DeLuise in between
cannibal or unsure my credit score was
actually lower than my cholesterol level
that's a you know you're a loser
all right Artie this is gonna be rough
all right so this next one is Blair's
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
[Music]
I want to touch that milk not slap
dial-up right it just feels like
something about to happen so it's not
good so you can't have Artie Lange on
first we feast without talking about
your love for food
what's your yelp review of your hot ones
experience so far unique which is tough
to do nowadays it's an original process
an original approach to the talk show if
you had to pick one food item to
represent the culinary Wonderland of New
Jersey what would it be peaches to
cliche I'd say I'd say an Italian hot
dog which is not what people think it's
not a sauce at a time I thought there's
an actual hot dog in a big peanut with
those catcher's mitt roll with peppers
potatoes mustard it's a jersey original
do you call it a fork roll or a Taylor
ham Taylor ham which is really weird
that's a very Jersey thing and it's not
trying to be cool about it that's just
what we call it sod
what was the meal that you missed most
when you were in jail
[ __ ]
I get that as a gift you actually do
this is the last dab it's called the
last dab because it's a tradition around
here to put a little extra of the last
wing right you don't have to if you
don't want to have to if you don't want
to arsenic
so there's stuff on your right yeah so
when I want on volution any later what
actually happens it's just a world you
just keep your head you know we go got
an ice pack if I wake up driving a
police car all right already
cheers my dead
mellow left but I could she
Tron
oh actually a very hot wife that's how
we made it yeah crystal was nothing
yeah it really puts things into
perspective Alan Tina there well what if
it was it cuz you go right to this
lightning round totally [ __ ] yeah yeah I
suppose this is the show this is hard oh
my god I take out an open cut in your
mouth wow that's something else all
right Artie it's been a roller coaster
ride through ten wings and now that we
have a belly full of chicken and hot
sauce I just have one more question for
you you're a man who's done a lot in
comedy you've written New York Times
bestsellers you've had a hot mic on the
best radio show in history directed
feature films but what's left on the
Artie Lange comedy bucket list what is
it that fuels that kid from New Jersey
who just loves to make people laugh well
right now the hope that hot sauce and
heroin make a unique hi which I imagine
it does I'll let you know about a motor
I probably love to go get coffee with
Jerry Seinfeld you want to be on that
show comedians and cars yeah I wanna I
want to get coffee with George huh and I
want to say that a lot of people mistake
me for uh
Newman a lot of chicks have left New
York chasing in big blue Newman look at
you Artie Lange and look glory of having
eaten ten wings
ten scorching hot chicken wings on
YouTube I don't know what it's like to
climb the top of Mount Everest but I
have a feeling you do now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet my man this camera this camera or
this camera let the people know what you
have going on you
come on a Sean hitch bill cool crash
I played me which said I'm on a podcast
called the RT and Anthony show with
Anthony Kuya
and also I have a book squall duh is
that blood or why bunch it's a party
no that was really unique I mean I wish
I got to sneeze again but okay that just
sort of relives it
hey what's going on hot ones fans a
quick heads up the second annual complex
con is coming to Long Beach California
November 4th and 5th and you know first
we feast and hot ones are gonna be in
the building there's gonna be a live hot
ones taping we're gonna be doing a panel
with my buddies Andy Milonakis and Matty
Matheson the last dab will be for sale
it's a whole thing
total circus hope to see you there